generally have virgins in them nope I
don't think the average virgins in them
no
explain what do you mean why I've got
real life proof examples of girls I've
met in church that are not virgins
so these non-virgins in church
do you think that
even the most pure place that women are
supposed to be Church
cannot stop human beings from being
promiscuous
I mean I think humans are promiscuous by
Nature I think that's just what we are I
think it's more socially accepted for
women to have sex now whereas before is
more frowned upon so it's okay women
have sex it's okay like it's not a this
big taboo thing anymore
um if we're talking about women still
we're talking about just men and women
yeah men and women yeah to virgins in
general I think humans are humans um I
think whether they're part of a church
or not I think maybe it's promoted more
to hold your virginity in a church but I
don't really see that being uh in my
experience where I grew up I didn't
really see that being a factor
you grew up in church bell
what was The Virginity like amongst the
people in church when you grew up
um
I mean I would say like it was just
delayed because I went to Catholic
school so everything that like
the public school kids were doing it
like 14 15 like we did just like when we
got to college I would say it was kind
of delayed
um the other church I was a part of was
like a Christian church and I would say
the girls there was a couple girls I met
there that like waited till they were
married to have sex but they got married
pretty young so I I don't see girls
being more pure like over a certain age
in church like if they do
if they are like they're married
typically at like 20 21 right like you
don't meet a lot of 25 year old virgins
in church no
um he didn't leave guys he just went to
the bathroom yeah
do you think Church nowadays because
I've been to a few churches
um I don't go to church anymore but
um I would look at the
the outfits in church from some of the
ladies right like do you think that
church promotes
Purity when it comes to like some of the
like things that people do in church or
do you think it's just like a show
conservative pure mindset where we don't
talk about sex because it's taboo and
you shouldn't have sex because you know
you will be judged and you have to you
know preserve yourself and that sort of
thing and I think naturally when people
are told that they can't do something
they kind of get more curious about it
um and I think we can kind of sexualize
anything if we feel like it
um so kind of
you know when you have like an
excessively pure space right it's really
easy to start sexualizing that because
that's kind of the whole
um opposite you know on the same
Spectrum right there's always going to
be a middle ground and you can really
kind of really project that onto it it's
it's easy to distort it like that if
that makes sense
I remember your video Power when you're
saying that um
these pastas are like oh
oh no okay I have this theory about
church yeah go on and I will say this
isn't my church because I grew up in
Catholics so Catholic was a little
different but I have this theory that
like the the
pastors are like the Homemakers and what
they do is they say you can be forgiven
for being a hoe because they want to
sleep with all the congregation because
that's what they do
so they're like yeah yeah you can get
forgiven and then they're like chatting
to him after and then
yeah so like and then they Market it
because what they'll do is they Market
wholeness because they have the Chastity
speakers come back and they're like yeah
I did this this and this and it's always
the girl that got ran through and then
the husband that married her and who did
it and he was like more pure and then
he's the the girl's like yeah um I got
ran through I did all this stuff but
then I found God and found my husband
and so they're like yeah you can just do
whatever you want and then still find a
husband at the end of it and so I feel
like in a way some Churches Market hodem
when you say ran through are you saying
being slept with with lots likes yeah
like like like you know yeah yeah like
like I slept with him and him and him
him him so like yeah I just wanted some
clarification on that I wasn't sure yeah
I don't know what the what would you say
is the specific point someone has ran
through
I don't know what the number is yeah no
I'm gonna leave those statistics to you
guys I mean I know I mean I've heard
I've had a lot of women in college have
trains running them that's it that's
that's I would say that's the definition
of being ran through it's like more than
like two sexual partners in a night too
sexual maybe two or three I don't know
four
yeah okay and so does that apply to a
male as well no no no absolutely not no
it's just it's just strictly
towards a female yeah well because men
and women are different it's hard for
men to get sex it's easy for women to
get sex okay all right sweet I'm just
yeah still just clarifying do you think
men can be hoes nope
why explain for a man to sleep with a
lot of women he has to be inherently
attractive or have value he can't just
run around sleeping with him it doesn't
work like that
but if he has is attracted and has value
and runs around sleeping with a lot of
women could he be a hoe no why because
again right attraction is a very
subjective term and women don't
typically look at a man's physical
appearance to determine traction they
typically look at behavior and like
communication style fine but if he
sleeps
sleep man sleeps with a lot of women
regardless of who he is you know how
attractive is value whatever if he's
sleeping with another woman wouldn't he
be a hoe you're applying the exact same
parameters but withdrawing well he can't
a man can't get pregnant right and so
there's no negative consequence to him
sleeping a lot of women
I mean STDs but also why is that
the application here is is that a woman
who sleeps with a lot of men right
that's that's because because that's
easy to do so it's like it's easy for a
woman to sleep with a lot of guys go
outside and say does anyone want to have
sex with me you can get it done if a
dude does that they look at him like
he's nuts
you know what changed my like
perspective on this is I went to a
pickup artist boot camp once this is the
wildest thing I've ever seen like these
guys paid thousands of dollars to learn
how to get laid Yeah thousands of
dollars and literally like went through
coaching like trying to figure out how
to build attraction with a girl like all
this stuff and I'm just like all I all I
have to do is exist so if you bring that
back too you'd have a vagina but if we
bring that back to what we're talking
about in terms of virginity when we were
younger in terms of like girls weren't
really thinking about it that much and
kind of saw it as this Victory right
isn't that what we're taught but that's
what's pushed onto us that men losing
their virginity and sleeping with lots
of women is like this you know like high
achievement so they pay lots of money
because if you get laid a lot then
you're seen as you know successful right
yeah I would say it is a high
achievement because historically most
men didn't even reproduce only 40 of men
reproduced historically where 80 of
women did and even up 8 000 years ago 17
women reproduced for every one man and
so it's it's like that's an achievement
most men don't even get to reproduce and
I know like now you know you take away
the reproduction because we have birth
control but you don't get rid of biology
so are we reducing it to reproduction
then so a woman who's that was the
initial yeah we've definitely developed
as a society right past that point where
it's not as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible